the unicycle one man one mountain the
Bloomberg south of Munich is more than
1,000 meters high the ground is soft
after heavy rains and the roots are
slippery perfect conditions according to
unicyclist sebastian needna left my
[ __ ] Smash Ball is actually more fun
when it's wet that makes it more
difficult and scary nuffin sighs neither
is one of germany's best unicyclists the
19 year old from munich turned
professional at age 11 since then he's
won World Championships and set world
records in the sport then goodnight
mohammed el estas a good unicycle is to
somebody who is tough if you fall down
you've got to get up again and carry on
and never give up done mostly I got an
ambition is always a part of it you have
to persevere and if you don't succeed at
first you must always try again until
you do when I most export lee side thank
you
straight to his favorite discipline the
downhill this involves peddling down the
mountain as quickly as possible the
foothills of the Alps are a popular
destination for walkers and mountain
bikers I think it's a lot more dangerous
when he's on his bicycle but on the
unicycle I know he's in control he picks
up the occasional scratch and might get
covered in mud and dirt but nothing
really bad happens to him unicycling
used to be associated with young
children and clowns today it's a real
sport people come from all over the
world to compete in tournaments like the
sods karma goot trophy in Austria the
sport is becoming increasingly popular
my mech Dashon does not end up with it
more and more people are turning
professional and they're getting younger
and better young my best isn't I noticed
that I wasn't writing as well as they do
now at that age so a lot of positive
changes are happening that Thailand
become meaner trains almost every day
unicycling is no longer just a toy for
him
pushing himself to the limit has won him
a string of medals some in quite
interesting disciplines he's a two-time
world champion in slow backward for
example he's clocked one minute and 12
seconds for traveling 10 meters in
Reverse that's a world record a unicycle
can cost between 150 and 500 euros
depending on the discipline need nur
takes seven with him two World
Championships he also teaches courses
for beginners and he's captain of a
Munich unicycle club yet this one then
there were people I used to idolize and
whom I was daunted by and now I've
become that person and I think that's a
very good development gotcha Nevada
gunman and he's determined to continue
that evolution and to carry on picking
up new titles and new records